Çeviri: Nihal Aksakal
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Benim lisedeyken bir hayalim vardı.
Lisede öğrenciyken
hayalim bankacı olmaktı.
Çünkü benim dedem bankacıydı.
Babam bankacı, amcam bankacı,
halam bankacı, kuzenim bankacı.
Bizde sülale mesleği bankacılık.
Ben de dedim ki madem öyle bütün
sülale bankacı, ben de bankacı olayım.
Hacettepe Üniversitesi
İktisat bölümünü yazdım.
Üniversitede okumaya başladım.
Birinci sınıfa giderken bir aile
dostumuz bana bir tavsiyede bulundu
ve hayatımı değiştiren olaylar
öyle başladı.
Dedi ki; "Albdulkadir sen bankacı
olmak istiyorsun
ama kaliteli bir bankacı olmak istiyorsan
ya da herhangi bir mesleği kaliteli bir
şekilde yapmak istiyorsan
çok ama çok kitap okumalısın" dedi.
"Bunun için de sana tavsiyem
bir hızlı okuma kursuna katılman."
Ben de tavsiyesine uydum,
anlayarak hızlı okuma kursuna katıldım.
Yaklaşık iki ayın sonunda
okuma hızım üç katına çıktı
ve bu sayede çok daha hızlı okuduğum
için daha fazla kitap okumaya başladım.
Sonrasında benim
çok büyük bir problemim vardı.
Üniversitedeyken,
öğrenciyken Türkçe dersi alıyordum.
Türkçe dersinde hocamız
bize ödev veriyordu, kitap okutturuyordu,
özetini çıkarttırıyordu ve bunu gelip
bizim amfide anlatmamızı istiyordu.
İlk dönem bir sunum yapmıştım,
inanılmaz derecede heyecanlanmıştım.
Heyecanım o kadar yüksek seviyedeydi ki
bir siyasetçinin başından geçenler az
daha benim başımdan da geçiyordu.
Siyasetle ilgilenen birisi bir gün
milletvekili olmaya karar veriyor,
aday adaylığı başvurusunda
bulunuyor, aday gösteriyorlar
ve tabii biliyorsunuz bu süreçte seçim
kampanyalarında mitingler gerçekleşiyor
ve mitingde de binlerce kişi toplanıyor,
burada olduğu gibi.
Burada kişinin ilk konuşması olacağı için
o kadar çok heyecanlanıyor ki
elleri ayakları titriyor, yüzü kızarıyor,
kalbi çarpıyor.
En son ismini anons ettiklerinde
kürsünün başına geldiğinde
heyecandan öldü ölecek,
o seviyede geliyor kürsünün başına
ve diyor ki;
''Sevgiili hemşehrilerim.
Buraya gelmeden önce
anlatacaklarımı bir Allah biliyordu,
bir de ben biliyordum.
Şu an sadece Allah biliyor.'' diyor.
(Kahkaha)
Heyecandan her şeyi unutuyor.
Ben de onun gibi heyecandan her şeyi
unutacak seviyede heyecanlanıyorum.
Allahım dedim, ben bunu çözemezsem
iş hayatında başarılı olamayacağım,
bunun muhakkak ama muhakkak
bir çözümü olmalı.
Topluluk karşısında konuşmanın
bir eğitimi olmalı dedim
ve araştırdım
ve buldum.
Bir eğitime katıldım
ve o eğitim benim hayatımı değiştiren,
belki de en faydalı eğitim olmuştu.
Hocam, o dönemde bana
topluluk karşısında konuşma
heyecanımı kontrol altına alabilmek için
dört tane alıştırma tavsiye etti.
Dört tane alıştırma
o kadar etkili oldu ki
şu anda sizin karşınıza gelip de
binlerce kişi karşısında konuşabiliyorsam
belki de o alıştırmaları
denilen şekilde yapmama borçluyum.
Şimdi, sizlerle bu dört tane
alıştırmayı paylaşacağım.
Bu topluluk karşısında konuşma
heyecanı olan
yani hocam, ben de şu sahneye çıktığımda
böyle kalabalık bir grup karşısında
konuşma yapacak olsam
çok heyecanlanırım diyen varsa
eminim ki bu alıştırmaları
yaptıktan sonra
heyecanını çok daha rahat
bir şekilde kontrol altına alacak.
Şimdi paylaşacağım bu dört
tane alıştırmayı
her kim ki iyi bir şekilde dinler,
anlar, uygular ve gider yedi
kişiye anlatırsa büyük sevaptır
bu aynı zamanda -
(Kahkaha)
Çünkü gerçekten yapılan
dünyadaki araştırmalarda -
ben çok araştırma yaptım bununla alakalı -
korkuları sıralamışlar, birinci sırada
topluluk karşısında konuşma
heyecanı geliyor.
İkinci sırada yaşamın sonlanması geliyor.
Yani çoğu kişi diyor ki
böyle konuşacağıma
insanlar karşısında ölsem daha iyi.
(Kahkaha)
Şimdi ilk alıştırma şuydu:
Bana dedi ki, ''Buradan çıkar çıkmaz
her gün, hiç ama hiç
tanımadığın on kişiye selam vereceksin.''
Nasıl yani? Bir dükkâna girdin,
dükkânın sahibini tanımıyorum,
selam vereceğim. Olur mu?
''Hayır olmaz.''
Yolda yürürken, karşından insanlar
geliyor, onlardan birini
gözüne kestireceksin,
karşıdakine bakacaksın,
güler yüzünle
''Merhaba, iyi günler.
Selamın aleyküm.'' selamlarından
birini yapıştırıp geçeceksin dedi.
Ben tabii bunu yapacağım ama
çok merak ediyorum ne olacak,
nasıl bir tepki verecekler.
Çekinerek de olsa yapmaya başladım
ve inanılmaz derecede hoşuma gitti.
İnsanlara selam verdim, birçoğu
selamımı aldılar,
bir kısmı selam almadan geçerken baktılar,
kimdi bu diye,
bir kısmı göz göze gelince korkup
kafayı öne eğdi.
Ama ben hiç bırakmadım.
Her gün o alıştırmayı yaptım.
İkinci haftaya geldiğimizde
şunu tavsiye etti:
Hergün iki yada üç kişiyle
iki-üç dakika konuşma yapacaksın.
Ama konuşmayı sen başlatacaksın.
Durakta duran insanların
yanına gideceksin,
kantinde sıra bekleyenlerin
yanına gideceksin
ya da herhangi bir yerde
bir insanın oturduğunu gördün,
sen inisiyatifi ele alarak
iletişimi başlatacaksın
ve bir şekilde muhabbet edeceksin.
Bunu da yaptım ve gerçekten de
iletişim becerimin gitgide
arttığını hissettim.
Üçüncü haftaya geldik.
Üçüncü haftada işi zorlaştırdı.
Dedi ki; bir şehrin, bir işlek cadddesine
çıkacaksın ve o caddede
karşı tarafa doğru bağıracaksın.
Ne diye bağıracağım dedim.
''Ahmet! Mehmet ! Süleyman! Ayşe!''
Bir isim telaffuz edeceksin
ama orada öyle biri olmayacak.
Dedim ben rezil olurum o zaman.
Dedi ki ''Zaten topluluk karşısında
konuşma heyecanı duymanın
en büyük sebebi rezil olma
korkun ve bir korkunun üzerine
gitmeden, o korku ile yüzleşmeden
onunla baş etmen çok zor,
adım adım yıkacağız bu korkunu.''dedi
ve caddelere çıktım, bağırmaya başladım.
Ahmetler, Mehmetler, Süleymanlar...
Baktım kimse bakmıyor, daha da coştum.
(Kahkaha)
Sonra dördüncü haftaya geldim.
Dedi ki ''İşte bu alıştırma var ya
senin rezil olma korkunu
yerle bir edecek, özgüvenini de tavan
yaptıracak alıştırma olacak.''dedi.
Ben de merakla bekliyorum ne olacak diye.
''Şimdi ki çalışmamız
eczane çalışması.''dedi.
''Ne yapacağız eczanede? '' dedim
''Eczacıya gideceksin ve şunu soracaksın.
Kandil simiti çıktı mı? ''
(Kahkaha)
Dedim ki ''Ben üniversite
öğrecisiyim, beni bilinçli
rezil edeceksin.''
''Evet, bilinçli bir şekilde
gideceksin ve rezil olacaksın.'' dedi.
Eczaneyi niye seçiyoruz?
''Onlar hergün hastalarla
uğraştığı için.'' dedi.
(Kahkaha)
''Çok bir tepki vermezler.
Kasap filan elinde-
bir şey fırlatır mazallah-
Neyse dedim, gideyim yapayım.
Gittim, yaptım ve harbiden
acayip bir duygu hissettim.
Bilinçli bir şekilde rezil olmuştum
ve rezil olma korkum yerle bir olmuştu.
Benimle birlikte bir sürü kişi
kursa katıldı.
Kursa katılanlardan biri daha sonra
anılarını anlattı.
Bu işin esprisi, bir dükkâna
girip o dükkânda olmayan bir şey istemek.
Bilinçli bir şekilde rezil oluyorsunuz
ama adım adım.
Selam, muhabbet, cadde, eczane.
İşte en son bu geliyor.
Bizim kursa katılan adamlardan
bir tanesi kuyumcuya gitmiş.
Demiş ki ''Burada kıyma var mı? ''
Kuyumcu ''Kardeşim burası kuyumcu.
Görmüyor musun?
Burada kıyma ne gezer?'' demiş.
Adam da ''Tamam.'' demiş, dışarıya çıkmış.
Sonrasını kendi şöyle anlattı, dedi ki:
''Hocam, ben kuyumcuya gittim
ve burada kıyma var mı diye sordum ya
sonra dışarı çıktığımda
şuramda bir şey hissettim,
bir özgüven patlaması yaşadım,
dayanamadım, coştum,
içeri tekrar girdim ve dedim ki
''Burada kıyma olmadığına emin misiniz?''
(Kahkaha)
Dedim ki ''Bunu tavsiye
ediyor musunuz insanlara?''
''İlkini tavsiye ediyorum ama
ikinci kez girmemek lazım.'' dedi.
Kovalamış adam.
Şimdi bunları yaptıktan sonra,
gerçekten şunu fark ettim:
Ikinci dönem bir sunum yaptım,
Türkçe dersinde, amfide, 100 almıştım
hocam '' Sen evrim mi geçirdin?''
dedi bana.
''Hocam kursa katıldım.'' dedim.
Sonra hızlı okuma,
hitabet, ders çalışıyorum
ama hafızama alamıyorum,
dedim ki bunları da yeneceğim.
Hafıza kursu, beyin dili
programlaması ile ilgili
kurslara katıldım.
Gördüm ki bizim muhteşem
bir beynimiz var
ve bu beyinde iki tane lob var,
biri sağ lob, biri sol lob.
Ama bizim eğitim sistemimiz
devamlı solu çalıştırıyor.
Mantık, sayı, yazma, listeleme,
detaylarla uğraşıyoruz.
Sağ taraf, hayal gücü, renk,
görüntü, duygu, his.
Bunlarla ilgili olan taraf sanki
stand-by modunda.
Neticesinde sol taraf sağ tarafa göre
daha çok geliştiği için
sol taraf daha fazla gelişiyor
ve aynen şuna benziyor:
Burada bir kuş var, diyelim ki,
salonun başından sonuna kadar uçacak,
ben bu kuşun sağ kanadını kırsam
uçabilir mi? Uçamaz.
Aynen böyle, eğitim sisteminde sağ taraf
fazla geliştirilmediği için
sanatsal faaliyetler, hayal gücü,
hayal gücünün öğrenme
sürecine aktif katılımı,
hayal gücünü kullanarak öğrenme
nasıl gerçekleşir, bunu bilmediğimiz için
tek kanatlı kuşlar olarak
uçmaya çalışıyoruz.
Uçamayan çocuklarımıza da baskı yapıyoruz,
sınavlarda başarısız oldukları için.
Dedim ki bunların hepsini
ben uyguladım, faydasını gördüm,
bankacılık hayallerimden vazgeçiyorum.
Bunları insanların öğrenmesi lazım.
Yıllar boyunca öğrenme gerçekleştiriyoruz,
öğrenmeyi öğrenmeden öğrenme
gerçekleştirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Ne yapabilirim dedim.
Hacettepe Üniversitesi'nde
önce Kişisel Gelişim
Kulübü'nü kurdum.
Uzmanları üniversiteye çağırdım.
Bunların anlatılmasını sağladım.
Baktım ki salonlar doluyor, taşıyor -
Kayseri'de ilkokul okumuştum,
girişimcilik ruhum kabardı.
Dedim ki ''Şirket kuralım.''
Eğitim Danışmanlık Şirketi kurdum.
Üçüncü sınıfta.
Etkinlikler yapmaya,
kurslar açmaya başladım.
Ama olay kulüpteki gibi gitmedi.
Kimse kursa gelmedi.
Bedava olduğu için geliyorlarmış.
Sonra, zorlandım. Düştüm.
Acı çektim.
O günlerde yanımda destekçi olarak
annem babam olmasaydı-
ki çoğu Türk ailesinin
yapmadığı bir şeyi yaptılar.
''Oğlum sen devam et bu işe.
Pes etme.
Hayallerinden vazgeçme.'' dediler.
Onların desteğiyle devam ettim.
Sonrasında, evlendikten sonra
eşimin desteği ile devam ettim.
Hepsine burada, sizlerin
huzurunda binlerce kez
teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)
Bir anne babanın evladına
yapabileceği en büyük şey
düştüğünde yardımcı olması,
bir tekme de onların atmamasıdır.
Ama bizde böyle olmuyor maalesef.
Devam ettim.
Dedim ki ''Bunu daha çok yayacağım.
Binlerce öğrenciye konuşacağız.
Türkiye turnesine çıkacağız.''
Hayaller kurdum, dedim ki
''Ben Türkiye'nin
seksen bir iline gideceğim.''
Nasıl gideceğim? Para lazım.
Dedim ki sponsor bulacağız.
O dönemde TTNET'e gittim,
onun öncesinde birçok kişiye gittim
ama kimse sponsor olmadı.
Bırakmadım, bulacağım
bu sponsoru ve gezeceğim,
bu üniversite öğrencilerinin
ufkunu açacağız, dedim.
Seksen bir illik bir proje yaptım.
Yetmiş yedisine kadar gidebildik.
TTNET ile Geleceğini Netleştir
Etkinlikleri kapsamında.
Belki burada da bu etkinliklere
katılan öğrenciler vardır.
2010-2011 yıllarında
yetmiş yedi farklı ilde,
doksan yedi farklı üniversitede,
yüz kırk etkinlik yaptık,
yetmiş iki bin öğrenci
bu eğitimlere katıldı.
Nasıl daha kolay iş bulabilirler,
hafızalarını nasıl geliştirebilirler,
iletişimi nasıl daha etkili kurabilirler,
bunları anlattık.
Birçok arkadaş bu sayede iş sahibi oldu.
Ufukları açıldı,
daha çok okumaya başladılar.
Başkalarına anlattılar.
Dedim ki ''Bu da yetmez.''.
Biz bir saat konuşuyoruz,
burada on beş dakika sürem var.
Bunları yapmakta yetmez.
Ne yapacağız?
Okul açacağız.
Dedim ki ''Eğitim, eğitim, eğitim.''
En önemli kısım eğitim,
buradan çıkmayacağım.
Atatürk de diyor ya,
''Eğitimdir ki bir milleti,
hür, şanlı, bağımsız,
yüksek bir topluluk hâline getirir
ya da sefalete ve esarete terk ettirir.''
Eğitimden başka
bir çıkışı yoktur bu toplumun.
Okullar kurmaya başladım.
Şu an iki tane okulum var.
2019'da başta Ankara olmak
üzere, on tane daha okul açacağım.
Nitelikli eğitimi Türkiye'nin
her tarafına ulaştırmak için çalışıyorum.
İnşallah, bu beş yıl içerisinde de
hedefim, hayalim
bir üniversite kurmak.
İş hayatına daha nitelikli
insanlar yetiştirmek -
(Alkış)
Çünkü dünya çok değişti.
Bu eğitim sisteminin
revize edilmesi lazım.
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı yetkilileri
canhıraş bir şekilde çalışıyorlar.
Hiç kimsenin eğitimi kötüye
götürmeye çalıştığını düşünmeyin.
Hepsi iyi niyetle çalışıyorlar.
Ama özel sektörün, insanların
da inisiyatif alması,
elini taşın altına sokması lazım.
O yüzden çok daha fazla
nitelikli eğitim kurumuna ihtiyacımız var.
Son olarak şunu söylemek istiyorum,
bu kısacık vakit içerisinde
hayatımı kısaca özetlemeye çalıştım
ve bazen soruyorlar:
''Hocam başarı ile ilgili
neyi tavsiye edersiniz? ''
''Hayatınızdaki prensipler nedir?''
diye sorduklarında,
Mehmet Akif Ersoy'un
İstiklal Marşı şairimizin
bir sözünü söylüyorum.
Mehmet Akif Ersoy diyor ki:
''Allah'a dayan, sa'ye sarıl,
hikmete ram ol,
varsa çıkar yol budur,
bilmiyorum başka yol.''
(Alkış)
Ben buna -
Başına iki şey daha eklemek istiyorum:
Hayal kurun, harekete geçin,
Allah'a dayanın,
çalışmaya sarılın,
O'nun takdirine rıza gösterin.
Yol varsa budur,
bilmiyorum başka çıkar yol.
Teşekkür ediyorum. Çok sağolun.
(Alkış)